Let's cover some UMG fundamentals first and how to set up your interface in the scene
that we'll be looking at today.
So to get started, we can open a blank template and we can create an empty level to begin
a project.
And then what we can actually do is add a feature or content pack into the existing
blank project so that we can just include some specific content for what we need today.
So we're going to include the vehicle template asset and we'll just click add to project
and this will give us access to this car model that you can see in the scene there.
So it's a nice clean way to work.
You don't have to come with all the bulk of other information from other content packs.
So go ahead and do that, save all and we're good to get started.
We'll be using the game mode today to store information and so I think it'd be useful
to cover what a game mode is and especially in relation to HMI.
So the game mode first of all is singleton so it can be accessed by any class, meaning
that whenever you have a session active, you can find the game mode based on any class
that's currently in that scene.
It holds data so you can easily access and store data inside the game mode.
And the cool thing about this is that it only exists as long as the level is open.
So we use the game instance and also save states for long term data storage.
So if you just want to access information during the actual session, then you can have
whatever variables or information you want to store inside the game mode and that will
be fine.
It's like a one shot use of data.
If we're wanting to maybe change the color of a car and actually save that information,
you wouldn't want to do that on the game mode.
You'd want to do it either in the game instance or in a save state.
So it's worth highlighting the differences there.
When we talk about controller in this instance in HMI, we're talking about something that
we can possess.
So we will when we load the session and play the session, controller will become active
and we can interact with this scene with our controller.
So for our purposes today, our controller will be our camera manager.
So it's a digital representation of a user and we possess it like a pawn in a scene.
It can have input assigned to it.
So we can bind either keyboard and mouse events or any other peripheral that you have plugged
in.
We can actually take input into the controller.
So it allows for a lot of flexibility there as well.
And as you can see in a HMI, the controller can be used to change the interaction modes
and manage the information as well.
So a lot of power in the controller and that is what we'll be using today to interact with
that scene.
A pawn on the other hand is a representation of generally your avatar in the world.
So it's the user's visual or digital form.
It's a CDO Singleton, but the HMI is like any visible pawn.
So we just possess a camera to see the visual elements and there's no visual element needed
because we don't need to move or manipulate anything.
And then in a standard HMI game mode, the pawn class is set to none.
So in that screen that we saw here, when we have a pawn class, we won't need any kind
of pawn class assigned because the controller will be handling everything in this instance.
And then looking at some default properties for our project settings, we want to go to
the edit button at the top of our Unreal Engine window and go down to project settings, which
you'll find towards the bottom.
And you can go to the maps and mode sections and we just want to change some of these properties.
So if you can't find any of these properties, there's a search bar at the top of project
settings, which you can easily find any of these parameters here.
But we want to change the game mode up here.
We want to change the default map to whatever map we want to load at the start and we want
to change the game instance.
So whatever you call your map, if you go to file, save as, and you call your map something,
for example, display map in this instance, you just want to make sure that that's assigned.
In case we package up the game or the executable and we want to share this with someone else,
that will load the correct map by default.
So it's worth keeping those settings in mind.
And today we'll be displaying some kind of data on the screen that we want to interact
with and we use UMG for this, which stands for Unreal Motion Graphics.
And they're the properties that you can see on the right hand side here.
And we can design those, which we'll jump into in just a few moments.
So what is this display of data?
So it's a collapse UI.
We have widgets as templates, so you can create a widget and assign it to various different
interactive elements throughout this HMI demo.
We have widget switches, which are contextual menu changes.
So we can switch from one menu to another menu.
We have widget layering.
We have text displays, as you can see on the right there, where you can format your text,
however you'd like it.
And we can actually bind events to the input of clicking any of these buttons.
So if we click this audio button, we can fire off some kind of logic, which will cause a
state change in this demo, which will be really powerful moving forward.